well I saw you posted a photo of how you
handle spit up and I oh sorry my dog
just barked at my husband
so apparently no sorry
barking but no I saw this photo that you
posted and your or if you just given up
on shirts cuz like you've got vomit
going down the back of you know what's
funny is someone asked me that other day
they go do you ever wear shirt and the
answer is not most of the time because I
guess when I work out at the house I
don't work out with a shirt on and then
I don't shower until you know seven
o'clock at night I just kind of leave
the shirt off yeah pursuing them holding
the baby I mean there's no point ruining
you know eight shirts turned they I
think my wife changes about 17 times
just from spit-up so oh my gosh I gave
up on nice things I just owned black or
white I'm just like whatever so I saw
the video showing you outdoors while
your quarantine II um what were you
doing in a tree like I saw this video of
you like trying to speak like we just
moved into a new house and we were kind
of exploring outside and my wife noticed
this vine hanging from the tree and my
kids were trying to swing on it and
Lauren was like I used to that when I
was little and she was like well let me
go try it I said how about you let me go
try it first just to make sure that it's
like stable and so I like yanked on in a
couple times and it felt fine and then
like I went for it and the limb just
snapped in half and I think I bruised my
button and I'm and I'm really
embarrassed that Lauren caught that on
video but you know let's just do around
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going